all right let's bring in the chair of
the labor party now and the shadow women
and equalities secretary annalize Dodds
good morning to you annalize thanks so
much for being with us I'm not going to
get you to comment on exactly what
dominic Rob was talking about as he says
there's an ongoing process I do want to
talk to you though a little bit about
um some of the measures that he
announced this morning about uh tougher
sentences for people involved in
domestic killings is that something that
the labor party would welcome
of course labor will welcome any measure
that will improve the safety of women
and girls but I have to say we've seen
really concerning developments over
recent years here you know if you look
since 2015 we've seen prosecutions for
domestic violence have while reports of
domestic violence have more than doubled
so we need really serious action to be
taken here that's not just around
sentencing because actually for very
many domestic violence victims they
simply are not getting to that stage of
anywhere near a prosecution that's why
for example we need to have domestic
abuse specialists in every 999 control
room Libra's already delivered that
where we have a labor police and crime
commissioner who's focused on improving
that service for those victims it's
really important we also need to see
more specialist ports because we've got
such a huge backlog around these kinds
of crimes and particularly crimes
against women and girls you know again
we've called for specialist rape courts
up and down the country to speed all of
this up because as I say for many women
they're not getting to that stage of
sentencing they're continuing to have to
live in fear because of those many
failures when it comes to both criminal
justice but also the policing system I'm
afraid that's been getting worse under
conservative-led governments so how much
extra money would the labor party a
labor government put into the justice
system
well actually if you look at the money
currently that's being lost I would say
particularly to our economy because of a
failure to deal with crimes of domestic
violence we're talking absolutely
enormous sums that's because we're not
dealing with these crimes properly at
the beginning so I don't think it's a
question of just pumping more money into
a system it really is a question of
making sure we get that response right
you know I've spoken with some women
where they've repeatedly had to make
calls on the police to stay safe it's
not been then properly joined up and
then we've seen terrible impacts for
them continuing for a very long period
of time now we need to do far better
around this and many labor police and
crime Commissioners are doing better and
they're managing to do that because
they've been listening they've been
listening to the survivors of domestic
abuse and that frankly is what the
conservatives need to be doing right now
um you will have of course seen this
morning we heard from a nurse who is
concerned about the payoffer that has
been put forward for NHS workers from
the government it's five percent with a
one-off pay deal the labor party have
never really said exactly how much they
would have given to nurses so do you
think this deal is enough
well that's because we don't want to see
ultimately governments that focus on
division that are making up figures out
of thin air and that aren't negotiating
and unfortunately the conservatives
refused to negotiate particularly with
the nurses and with paramedics for a
really long time those nurses and
paramedics offered to call off that
industrial action to not go ahead to
strikes way back right before Christmas
now if conservative ministers had
actually sat down with the nurses and
paramedics back then we wouldn't have
seen I think it's 140 000 operations and
appointments being canceled because of
that industrial action so the important
thing here is negotiation the
conservatives should have negotiated
earlier with those nurses and paramedics
they need to be negotiating now with the
junior doctors not waiting but sitting
down with them today and getting a
resolution to this that is what's
necessary you know under labor
governments we didn't have a single
strike that was a national strike in the
NHS
let me let me just put it to you to you
this way then so the five percent is an
offer with a one-off uh payment
um you won't tell me exactly how much
the labor party would put in but would
you be backing the unions the GMB and
the other units the RCN and encouraging
members to vote for this offer
well the unions are currently speaking
with their members it's ultimately their
decision but no I'm not going to State a
figure out of thin air why because
negotiation is what is important here
and if we'd seen that negotiation
between conservative ministers and NHS
staff taking place when it needed to
when it was called for and when those
strikes could have been called off we
wouldn't have seen that negative impact
on patients and all of those operations
being canceled
so you'd be happy to see um workers
reject this payoff for enough for
strikes to continue
I don't want strikes to continue and in
fact labor from the very beginning said
the industrial action would be damaging
nobody knows that more actually than
patients and people working in the
service those NHS workers that's why
when there was the opportunity for
conservative ministers to sit down with
the nurses and paramedics Before
Christmas to get these strikes called
off Libra called on conservative
ministers to swallow their pride and
actually negotiate they refuse to have
those proper discussions back then they
took far too long we saw a huge impact
on our NHS 140 000 operations and
appointments being canceled and really
our patients and our NHS deserve better
than that
okay annalize Dodson chair of the labor
party to appreciate your time this
morning thank you